so
both of them
two lines
enemies your brain
emily is pregnant again
and based on what kobe says
you told me you have this application on
your phone like i'm not ovulating right
now you can me
i have no clue why they are so shocked
can't believe this is really happening
of course all this comes after he and
emily promised her dad not to have any
more kids under his roof and now for
good reason kobe is terrified and i'm
just so afraid
yet emily is feeling some type of way
that he's not happy about the situation
are you tripping honestly it kind of
hurt my feelings let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicio
before we get into the baby news and i
give you a quick update on bilal and
chida
i'm gonna tell you a little bit of my
business okay
i've been going through a growth spurt
lately spiritually mentally and
emotionally
it's been a lot and i'm sure some of you
are probably going through the same
thing
we're gonna get through this okay
anyway over the weekend i was feeling a
little down and my mom sent me some of
your comments the positive ones
and it really helped me put things into
perspective
i'm someone who always wants more and
more and more
and reading some of the nice things that
you all have said
it just made me realize that i need to
stop and be grateful for what i have now
so
thank you for the reminder to stop and
smell the roses
smells really good this was once a dream
for me to produce a show and to talk to
you all like this so
thank you
all right enough of me
shaida is out here stressing her and
below they have about a month left
before they have to get married and
during this episode shaida tells balau
how she was offended that his ex-wife
confronted her about signing the prenup
i felt as if she came with an agenda
to
to bully me and intimidate me
in my own house by the way i saw that a
lot of you were not feeling his ex-wife
and her approach i have to know you're
not here for just what he has
ronnie took it a step further and said
the real question is
why is he talking to his ex about his
current relationship
um
as shatter says too many hands in the
brought to sustainability saying train
having too many hands and abroad it
spoils the entire thing
below agrees that it wasn't his
ex-wife's place to bring up the prenup i
think chad is making valid points that
she feels that certain topics are just
for us and then he goes on to pull out a
hard copy of the contract
so shada can look through it
despite how hoods unaffected i am you
just nothing could change your mind
why are you so hurt
because prenups are never fear
never fail it's never fair how do you
it's always the more money spells
one to go into a prenup
because so far you're presenting me with
what you want to protect what you have
for you
those are the things that
you have before you shaida ends up
revealing the deeper reason to why she's
against this prenup and what she said
was something i didn't even think about
this prenup kind of shows me how hard i
have to work here it's about us building
together you know what that below
if i want to be a stay-at-home mom
i kind of do that because with this
prenup basically if i'm a stay-at-home
mom and something happened to us we'll
escape a scenario and we don't make it
what's going to happen to me i have to
go back home because i didn't i stay
home take care of your children and i
didn't build myself so just holding this
print up it shows how hard i have to
work in the united states so that i
could get something for myself you can
tell below didn't think about it either
she made a good point that's not a
thought you always want to have in the
back of your mind
but also in my opinion
this just shows how much bilal isn't
thinking about having children with
chida you know what that below
if i want to be a stay-at-home mom
i cannot do that
it doesn't seem as if he's even looked
at that as a factor
we were to split up body force
where there's one year 10 years or 25
years from now
nothing in the prenup covers me says
that bilal will mean with what he has
and whatever i accumulate in our
marriage it has to be joint hold up hold
up hold up hold up
what
that's what i read and i didn't like
that because i had something that
belongs to me back home
yeah i don't like that either what'd she
accumulates has to be joined
clearly i'm not a lawyer and i am not
savvy when it comes to prenups but that
doesn't sound fair to me if you are
familiar with prenups let me know if
that sounds right to you
below goes on to tell shaida that as
long as she doesn't cheat on him or
divorce him the prenup will not come
into play
i'm sorry this is not funny but
it's just a lot
i also know that i have two children
that i also have to protect as well
and i can't just say oh well let me just
uh have
a blind eye at love
well doesn't that's that that wouldn't
be smart
i know this is not the sexiest
conversation to have but i know it's a
conversation that is needed
this right here is something
that
just says that you won't
take me for everything i got i mean just
literally i don't i
like just see it from that standpoint
shada is going to take the time to
review the prenup on her own
but she also makes it clear that she's
going to ensure her needs are met in the
contract i'm not going to sign a
document that does not give me certain
rights in it
unless he put these things in a prenup
to protect me
it would leave me no choice
but to go back home to trinidad i know
some of you are thinking girl go home
a few of you have been saying that
z i'm just gonna call you z says quote
i'd sign his prenup but he'd also have
to sign mine my prenup would read that
should said husband become involved in
any infidelity whether actual or
attempted
weather said wife finds out at the time
of occurrence or after the fact said
husband's prenup immediately becomes
null boy and unenforceable
hey z
i'm not mad at that when below tells
chida that as long as she doesn't cheat
on him or divorce him the prenup will
not go to use
my first thought was what if he cheats
on her
she shouldn't have to feel trapped now
i'm sure he would say he would never
cheat on her but if you're going to do
this let's go ahead and cover all the
variables so she can have more of a
sense of security
and speaking of that next week bilal
basically tells shaida that he is not
her prince charming coming to the rescue
you love love but you put business first
when i first came here like for me was
like a storybook love cinderella love
that never exists
i gave up so much to come here
but i'm prepared to walk away the
cinderella stuff
is not real
[Music]
that's a hard appeal to swallow but
below speaking facts what did i say last
week
as kids they sold us a dream with these
fairy tales
yes love can be beautiful
but nothing is perfect
oof that was supposed to be a quick
update my bad
let's go ahead and move on to how emily
and kobe found out she's pregnant after
they promised emily's dad they would not
have any more babies while staying under
his roof
they already have two-year-old cobin
plus they aren't financially stable it's
just something you're not telling me at
the top of the episode emily takes kobe
on a trip with her to the pharmacy
because her cycle is laid
no you can't be pregnant
why can't i be pregnant
and kobe is freaking out
i don't know how i'm going to be able to
face your family if you're pregnant
but he also admits he was shooting up
the club that's more slang what did i
say when i was like babe i'm going to
take my birth control what did you say i
gave you a reason why i've seen women
who were on birth control and when they
wanted to conceive it was very how do
you know that they just told you that oh
my goodness
well i just said pull out
yeah
i pulled out they are telling us all
their business you told me you have this
application on your phone
like i'm not ovulating right now you
can't me
wow based off how shocked kobe is
he obviously took emily at her word
but to be honest i think deep down this
is something they both wanted maybe
because i mean what else would you
expect to happen
here they are you trying yeah
should have got condoms
emily and kobe go to the bathroom at the
pharmacy to take the test because emily
doesn't want to chance someone at the
house finding it
and once they come out they reveal the
big news
oh my goodness
if i could count how many times kobe
says oh my goodness
that is his thing
oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness
oh my god
oh my god
so
both of them
two lines
like i'm seriously pregnant that's like
two tests that say positive
so what are we going to do now
can't believe this is really happening
obviously we're not going to tell
anybody emily tells kobe that they're
going to keep this a secret from her
family until after the wedding which
made me nervous for kobe specifically
because emily might feel okay playing
these games with her dad
but her dad doesn't know kobe kobe is
not his child there is only so much
grace he's gonna give them in
i don't know how
i'm even gonna be able to look at her
parents you know especially at that
and i'm just so afraid
her family is going to see him some
camera even guy who is just interested
in having kids without even securing a
bright future for the children and stuff
like that it gets to a point where it
seems like emily is starting to accept
that she's pregnant but kobe is still
having a hard time taking it in
which gets emily and her feelings i mean
like what are you even feeling right now
it's already happened it's not like
something that we can change
it's already happened
we add up to irresponsible so okay are
you happy you're not happy you're not
even answering the question
it's just so heavy right now
i mean there's more pressure on me than
there is on you because i'm the only one
who has to make all the money and get us
out of them wow
for now
oh dang i kind of feel bad for kobe
although as a 30 plus year old man he
should have known what this
would lead to
you can see in his face how devastated
he really is
on top of the pressure to provide for
his family
more than likely he's going to lose the
little respect he does have from emily's
dad
i thought he would be a little bit more
excited because he wants kids and i get
it clearly not a good time but i can
tell by his tone of voice that he wasn't
happy about it
and honestly i kind of hurt my feelings
as it like takes two to tango and
obviously i didn't make a baby by myself
see it sounds like emily was well aware
of what she was getting into
now as far as her being upset that he's
not happy about it
i think she's just misplacing energy
in my opinion his reaction to her being
pregnant is more of a positive sign
it bothers him that he didn't keep his
word to her family and now he's feeling
intense pressure to step up
that's nothing to take lightly
either way they were both being reckless
but i'm sure they don't regret it now
if the rumors are true they have a
beautiful baby girl so congrats to those
two
as you can see things are heating up for
emily and kobe
and next week kobe is sweating as he
goes to get some advice from his friend
temperature
that was kind of corny but cute
big carpet
temperature is like a brother to me how
how do i do putting poo
my brother
emily doesn't want me to tell anybody
about the pregnancy but
i need to relieve myself from this load
she's pregnant again the way temperature
described emily was interesting how how
how do i do clinton pool i can't wait to
see how his personality is
i've never encountered someone with the
name temperature
[Music]
okay stop
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]